hey guys it's Ryan right here I just got
back from Fresno went to the haunted
maze based off the gallows the writer
and directors they put it together
themselves it was really [ __ ] scary
I'm gonna have a vlog coming up a bit
soon stop just a GoPros and [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] cool but today I'm checking out
sure that everyone's asked me to check
out literally everyone triple nine the
official red band trailer Aaron Paul
Kate Winslet a duo that I saw coming
from a long miles away there may be some
red damn worthy [ __ ] yeah
spend my time trying to make a
difference Casey Affleck
I know make it [ __ ] different forget
about that your job out posture the
memories then get home at the end of the
night
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] god damn that film looks like [ __ ]
it looks like disturbing violin like it
has like this vibe of badass action film
cool criminal characters it also has
like a rawness to it like a really raw
violent tone going on and the imagery
like the stunts look [ __ ] incredible
like they look like real stunts you know
this doesn't look like some pg-13 or
half-ass r-rated [ __ ] this looks
like they're goin all out our rating but
they're getting a great cast together
I'm hoping that if they're able to
assemble such a great cast of a lot of
really well-known names that will give
us a movie with a great script in great
direction to what point I thought I
confused Norman Reedus with Casey
Affleck but then I realized I was
correct that's the whole thing I was
saying during the trailer just to clear
the last scene they show where they get
out of the car and they start shooting
everyone that [ __ ] was [ __ ] like
intense man [ __ ] massacre dude like
this trailer is looking like okay this
is just gonna be some badass action
flick but then you see there's like this
authenticity to it that seems kind of
disturbing at times I like that point
where the guy checks him and then just
shoots him in the head as well like damn
yeah there was like a true detective
vibe about it and what do you Harrelson
at the beginning he makes a believable
drunk that guy knows how to play drunk
people well in case the athlete gets a
chance to look more badass too you know
I can't really recall roles where you
know Casey Affleck feels like a badass
to me like there's roles where he's cool
there's roles that I really like him in
but rare is around like damn he looks
badass
having Norman Reedus in it it seems like
a perfect addition to this cast know
everyone knows Norman Reedus is the [ __ ]
I mean what's really cool you got
[ __ ] Daryl from The Walking Dead and
Jesse from Breaking Bad coming together
in a movie that's awesome because you
know they're both on AMC maybe maybe it
takes place after Breaking Bad but
before The Walking Dead
I know I'm the first one to come up with
that I really share what Kate Winslet's
role is but she looks like a woman in
power some some way
I like how she does that sometimes now
she plays the woman in power I don't
know how people are gonna feel about
that Piggy song but I thought it was
cool I hope they use it in the movie you
know it's like a play on it because
they're pigs anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it subscribe today and get rejected
up the ass follow us on Facebook
Instagram vine Twitter and periscope yes
see him Annette's hey real rejects can i
have a shout out you guys especially you
run always make me laugh and just makes
my day better i'd also like to mention
jerry he is also awesome dude Jesse
human as of course we will give you a
shout out my friend Jerry's not here
today but Jerry is awesome
I want you guys to do me a favor first I
want Jesse to lead this Jesse tweet
immediately and reasons to Jerry you
have the darkest and curliest pubic hair
I know so
because Ryan Wright told me so I'm gonna
repeat Jesse tweet him at reasons to
Jerry I know you have hashtag curly
hashtag dark hashtag pubic hair I know
so because at the real Ryan Wright told
me so that's your job Jesse that's your
new job five hundred dollars